our show was asked not too long ago if
we would exclusively announce the lineup
for the 2016 Bonnaroo Music & Arts well
here's a story we were we were all set
to go very excited that we had the
exclusive when last week some of the
lineup was leaked online okay
you'd think that would steal our thunder
right no no way no not gonna stop us
because we got the official official
lineup that's not official until you
heard it right here there's some amazing
bands on this list are you ready Andy to
hear I sure AM I'm here all ears all
right here we go appearing at Bonnaroo
2016 check it out Pearl Jam dead and
company for the time this week mean
the chainsmokers
letting delirium Linda got many many
more
[Applause]
now I did mention some of that
information was leaked online before we
could announce it all right
but there's one appearance at this
year's Bonnaroo that no one knows about
it's an announcement entirely exclusive
to our show this is real in fact they're
right behind our curtain waiting to be
finally revealed this is huge huge I'm
thrilled thrilled to announce that
appearing at Bonnaroo this year for the
first time ever flushable toilets
[Applause]
that's right for the first time ever
Bonnaroo will feature flushable toilets
toilets by that's right American
Standard toto Barnum Kohler
[Applause]
he's kind of - go to Bonnaroo calm slash
tickets don't forget to go to Bonnaroo
this year it's going to be a great time
isn't that right flushable toilet
[Applause]